[Music]
so in the recent Dragon Ball super
special Goku finally revealed his new
form ultra instinct here his eyes glaze
over and he's able to react with
superhuman reflexes and finally put up a
good fight against jiren the really cool
thing about this state is it's actually
inspired by some real-life phenomenon in
fact the awesome youtuber jax blade
recently did a video discussing how it's
very similar to a state in martial arts
known as motion but if you're a fan of
this channel then you'll also know that
machine itself is very similar to a flow
state so I'm going to talk a little bit
more here about what a flow state is and
a new interesting way of potentially
unlocking it that I've been researching
lately when a flow state you're 100%
concentrating on a single event or task
and this allows you to perform with
superhuman ability some have called it
the ultimate state of peak human
performance which is quite hyperbolic
but does seem to have some merit so this
is when time seems to slow down and
you're able to react with superhuman
reflexes it's when you're writing an
essay and you're so into it that you
forget to go to the toilet it's when
you're in a fascinating conversation and
you're able to talk all through the
night and you lose track of time
neurologically what's going on here is
that the prefrontal cortex the part of
your brain involved in planning and
reflection this kind of shuts down and
so does your default mode Network the
part of your brain involved in
daydreaming and thinking about the
future
so this closes down and puts you in a
state known as temporal hypofrontality
meaning in other words temporarily your
frontal regions of your brain are
shutting down
allowing you to become that creature of
pure instinct
[Music]
so this has a lot of similarity with the
state in martial arts in emotion which
is mind without mind where you are
reacting once again on pure instinct and
it enables you to fight much more
quickly to react much more quickly
because you don't have that small
thought process that's going on inside
your head so according to authors like
Steven not lo who wrote the rise of
Superman there's 17 different flow state
triggers and these include things like
deep embodiment when you're being flung
around and you're having to use your
balance or you're falling rich
environment so when there's a lot of
interesting things going on around you
the correct
skill - difficulty ratio so that what
you're doing is difficult but not so
difficult that you don't think you can
do it it's just hard enough that you
need to focus but not so hard that you
become disheartened high reward and risk
these help you achieve flow basically a
flow state is very similar to the
fight-or-flight response but where
instead of being terrified and shaking
on the spot you're calm and in control
so what's happening is very important
even rewarding or dangerous but you feel
like you can do it you can just about do
it if you put all of your concentration
on to that one thing so common
situations where people might experience
flow or when they're surfing or when
they're snowboarding moving at high
speed but they're loving it and that
means there are hundreds don't focus
because they have to be in order to
survive but they're not scared they're
calm at the same time in the brain
you're producing a lot of
neurotransmitters such as dopamine
norepinephrine inand amide serotonin so
you alert and you're aroused but you're
also calm and you're loving it you're
feeling blissful and you're also usually
exhibiting slower brainwaves which are
on the cusp between alpha and theta so
if you're in a fight or if you're
snowboarding off you're playing sports
and you feel like the challenge is high
the stakes are high but you've got what
it takes then hopefully there's a high
chance you'll achieve flow and if you're
falling or if there's a lot of sensory
input at the same time then those
chances got even higher during an essay
or doing some kind of work if you're
getting immediate feedback
can you feel feeling very motivated
you're interested in that topic then
once again there's a higher chance that
you're going to achieve flow but it's
still quite an elusive goal we don't
know exactly what triggers flow it might
be different for different people and
you can't always be surrounding yourself
with rich environments and you can't
always be falling down the mountain so
how do you trigger that flow state when
you really need it what are some tricks
and methods you can use well in my
research I found one particularly
interesting method and it's called
wide-angle vision it's also sometimes
known as Owl Eyes this is apparently how
the Native Americans referred to it and
it can be called splatter vision the
idea is that normally we focus on one
thing we've been trained to focus on one
thing we spend so long reading our
phones looking the computer screens
reading books speaking to a person that
we rarely use the full wide-angle
capability of our eyes we just focus on
that one thing and switch our focus to
the point where it's become habits that
even when relaxing we're still focused
on one thing it's even been suggested
that this might be where some of our
vision problems start to come from in
the later life because we're not
exercising our abilities to focus at
different ranges in wide-angle vision
you're rediscovering that ability to
focus on lots of things all at once to
be aware hyper aware of your
surroundings and the way you do this one
way to achieve it is by stretching your
arms out you can't see mine wiggling
your fingers whilst looking forward and
watching your fingers as you do try it
now I'll give you a moment and then try
and hold on to that state and you should
find that now you're not focusing on one
thing in the middle but rather you have
a kind of blanket vision of everything
going on you've lost some detail you've
lost some precision but you've gained a
much broader gamut of stimuli coming in
now a lot of people will use this during
survival training that walk through the
woods
using this wide-angle vision and they
use it in order to see more interesting
wildlife as they go to spot potential
predators to spot potential food
likewise if you notice animals they
don't stare at one thing they tend to
have this kind of wider field of view if
you notice any movement happening
anywhere within that field of view then
your attention will be brought there
even though you don't have that same
level
detail and precision is enough to know
what you need to direct your attention
to apparently in the FBI they use this
technique and they call it splatter
vision they trained their agents this
way in order to allow them to scan a
crowd of people more effectively to look
for targets or potential threats or to
scan their environment to look for exits
and potential weapons I can tell you
that our waitresses left-handed and the
guy sitting up at the counter weighs 215
pounds and knows how to handle himself I
know the best place to look for a gun is
the cab of the great truck outside this
could raise your situational awareness
as well and maybe one day save your life
and the even cooler thing about
wide-angle vision is that it increases
your reaction time and allows you to
block attacks more quickly catch balls
and just perform better athletically and
there's a few reasons this might be the
case the first is that when you have
this wider angle vision you have more
context for what's going on in your
field of view if you've ever been
driving in the dark you'll notice you
feel like you're moving faster that's
because your vision is narrowed you can
see less and thus there's less context
things seem to be coming out of nowhere
if you can see more then you seem to be
moving slower because you can see those
object coming sooner you can see them in
relationship to other objects in your
field of view so when you engage this
wider field of vision you can likewise
see things coming sooner and you can
gauge the distance in their speed more
effectively thus almost seeming to
dilate time giving you more time to
react to whatever it is you need to
attack and react to and another possible
reason that time seems to slow down
might be that you're achieving a flow
state so the guy who coined the term
flow state mihály chits and Haley I'm
sorry I do not know how to say it I know
it's hypocritical coming from a guy
called Adams and it's key anyways he
says that we have roughly a hundred and
ten bits of information that we can
attend to at any given time speaking
alone apparently takes sixty bits of
information normally our brain is kind
of scattered among these different
things so we're focusing on one thing
and another thing on another thing but
during a flow State all 110 bits are
focused on that one activity and thus of
course we're going to perform better
because we have more processing power
committed to that one task and if you're
engaging your wide-angle vision
basically what you're doing is you're
inviting more information
in through your eyes and that gives you
more information to attend to meaning
that you can't attend to those other
things you're pushing out those things
that don't matter so that you're just
focused on what's happening right now
and thus you in experience deeper
embodiment and presence in the current
moment and when you look at more things
you'll find that you also hear more
things because your vision directs your
other senses if you want to learn more
about that and check out my video on
daredevil training and one more reason
that wide-angle vision could trigger a
flow state is that it puts you in a
state of calm so when you're panicked
when you're scared you do focus on just
one thing you gain tunnel vision
you're so focus on that one thing
because it's probably gonna kill you and
your heart rate raises your body knows
something's wrong when you're looking at
a wider vision of the world
you're signalling to your body that
there's nothing inherently immediately
dangerous happening right now
you've got this you're calm and so of
course your response comes down as well
and you produce from all of those alpha
and theta brainwaves and you can respond
to it and then engaged but to calm
manner rather than a scared
fight-or-flight response
essentially a flow state is fight or
flight response scared in trouble but
then I've got this karma is a karma
response to something that needs a
hundred percent of your attention you
can achieve this with wide-angle vision
and I'm going to talk in the future
about how you can achieve this with
different breathing techniques such as
warrior breathing the martial arts do
incorporate all this in fact one
Waterloo karate kata starts with a move
designed to engage your peripheral
vision and potentially help you achieve
motion it starts with your hands in
front of you you raise them slowly and
draw a circle the idea is that you watch
the hands all the way around and in
doing so you've achieved peripheral
vision and potentially increased your
chances of attaining motion of course
it's also important like I said that the
karateka have practiced their moves over
and over again so that whilst they're
reacting quickly without that extra
conscious thought their body knows what
to do and how to respond to an attack
and yeah all this is pretty close to
what Goku does in that episode when he
achieves ultra instincts in fact in the
show his eyes even turned silver
indicating their importance we one
problem with all this is that too many
people a flow state is slightly
different than what I've just described
as being motion to many people a flow
state means focusing on one
intently and what's that got to do with
wide-angle vision what does writing an
essay have to do with wide-angle vision
likewise many people say creativity is
increased during flow State and what
does that have to do with any of this
well my theory is that actually the term
flow State is used to broadly I think
that what we call a flow state is
actually lots of different flow States
it makes sense to me that
neurochemically skiing down the mountain
is different to writing an essay I think
that some people like Steven not I have
a tendency to describe flow States as a
kind of Panettiere a solution to
everything when in fact we have lots of
different mental states all of which are
useful and the most optimum performance
comes from being able to switch between
them at the right time I also think that
it's important sometimes to daydream I
think the default mode network is very
important and that we shouldn't throw
the baby out with the bathwater so in a
future video I'll discuss this in more
detail I'll talk about different types
of beneficial mental States and how to
achieve them but for now I think that if
you want to achieve the flow state that
is most similar to motion then using
wide-angle vision is one cool way that
you can do it I'd like to know what you
think in the comments down below I just
hope that the Goku discovers this before
jiren eliminates him and universe 7 is
destroyed so thanks a ton for watching
guys I hope you found this video useful
and interesting if you did then please
leave a comment down below and let me
know what you thought please share
please like please subscribe please hit
the bell button so you get notifications
all of this helps me immensely and if
you would like to help the channel then
please also check out my social media
links in the description down below
follow me on Instagram where I post my
workouts and my productivity tips and on
Instagram I've said Instagram on Twitter
on Facebook but you can follow whatever
I'm getting up to all this helps a lot
with the channel and like I've said in
the past I'm really building this up and
putting a lot of effort into it at the
moment to try and grow it in the future
I've got tons more videos coming on all
these same topics new @ro pics workouts
I'm going to be talking about metabolic
conditioning soon and how to raise your
energy levels so if all that sounds
interesting then please hit subscribe
and thanks so much for watching I'll see
you next time bye for now